okay four people joining the livestream
this is a meeting about incremental
language development for wolfing
language and we have a variety of topics
here starting with date interval okay
should I be looking at the documentation
pages here is bliss the functionality is
in the X column okay I better start an
external one okay we very much discussed
this right yes yes there were some final
things like how do we decide the default
granularity and things like that but I
think we managed to to get this
correctly crime eternity I like that
yeah we need that for the past infinity
and future infinity but we call them
infinite future and infinite past I
think that's better than the general 30
terms I mean for our purposes do you
agree past infinity is very much a point
in space-time but most people don't
think in space-time
what's this millennium beginning is that
a new thing no we always had that to
resolve the ambiguity between starting
in 2000 or 2001 not so same way we
documented it I think so I guess here
you can just copy the table from the
other
the page date object to me okay no date
object also has properties right
yes it does and then we have a function
called date value which even more
powerful on what to state value to on
date enter all good question
I guess the properties the properties
that are shared will work as well okay
so if I say data interval and now to
tomorrow right so you see that in this
case we always take the finest
granularity which in this case is
instant so that's how it's resolved okay
is there a possibility we could align
these columns here I guess we can or is
that inconsistent with our other we
typically don't align the various fields
but in this case because it's so
symmetric perhaps it's worth trying I
think it's worth trying it and I think
we should be changing these calendar II
things anyway yeah I think we could
totally remove the kinda I don't even
know whether we needed a tenth of a
wrapper outside this weather we can just
have a well- to particular itself yeah I
mean this is kind of nice but I mean we
can certainly do one iteration like this
um we have both presidents I mean
psyched
I mean this gets more widely used we'll
want to ok so then now if I say duration
of this oh yeah the function yes we have
the property duration okay okay now date
bounds is that also a function yes and
we have now mean date max date
why is that not just min and Max because
they also support I know they'd strings
and things than that
do we care about date strings I'd be
happy to only support date object would
live without them I think in some
previous meeting we decided it was a
good idea to have them but well maybe
they'll have some extra feature writing
for example I think that's the issue is
the granularity isn't it it's helpful
certainly because it avoids writing the
result on another date object
okay in fact I think we decided that
they'd bounce should also gain they can
write the argument definitely but
duration is just while it has a kind of
Oh still future eyes yeah I think he
just sounded it okay okay
what other functions like duration okay
what were plotting support for the stuff
at the moment it's supported by timeline
plot and yeah in it in some other places
ago she is also working on supporting it
in time series also the past in infinite
feature an infant past she has done that
already
we need to propagate the subject and
through other places functions like
weather data yes except well and dated
presumably needs this dated needs the
sleet the possibility of a date interval
as a second argument right because dated
this will also be important for
historical stuff reporting periods yes
yes that's true
the only an issue which is that many of
those historical periods have a much
larger granularity on the beginning than
at the end and these data interval
object forces the same general team both
so sigh yeah that's I'm thinking about
perhaps allowing for date interval the
second argument to be a pair so that you
can specify the generality of the
beginning or of the end what what is the
realistic thing that the you know the
Bronze Age started at this time but and
the dinosaurs started a vague time but
ended the particular day of the KT you
know of the of the asteroid impact I
don't know is that the type of thing you
have in mind yes or a country we we
don't know exactly what it contra
started but it ended in a very precise
date about or something so it happens
sometimes in historical country data but
somehow I have the impression that this
is not so much about molarity but about
imprecision it's more like the date is
fuzzy more than generality I agree I
mean look it's Anna it's an around for
for dates
exactly yeah so perhaps the solution is
not to really allowing more flexible
specifications but allowing are wrong
yeah I think I think what would the
right thing is look the country it is a
little weird isn't it because a country
might end a particular day it will be
unlikely to say then at a particular
hour but there will be a day when you
know some surrender was signed or
something right and then I mean I think
this is a rare case but you know then
the granularity will be a day like
granularity but it's pretty weird to say
you know Rome was built in a day well I
don't know it's known by the year right
when you know what a 410 AD or whenever
it was the barbarians or whoever they
were attacking Rome that wasn't that
sort of known to the year but well and
they've had a founding day right it had
a yeah it had it had a
official founding date Rome did because
they quoted dates from the founding date
but I'm sure the actual in a romulus and
remus you know that's a fuzzy date I
don't know this seems like a corner case
to me and it seems like probably we
should handle it using it around inside
Oh though gosh I have no idea how much
difficulty there isn't supporting around
inside data at all so um I'm trying to
support a run outside dates in the sense
of a round of a date plus minus or
quantity that's very reasonable
but these somehow requires the around
inside because we have to put it in the
initial date so that's the thing that is
a bit strange but I fully agree with you
that their proper way to solve this is
be around not vehicle relatives yeah
well kind of I mean there are things
look the formation of a country you
might know to within a year or a decade
you're unlikely to know it to the day
except in very weird cases maybe I don't
know I don't know I don't know history
is complicated
um alright so but but ok dated clearly
needs this is a bunch of financial data
that will need this basically we should
look at what functions can take a date
yeah there are many functions taking up
their time series for example ok ok now
supporting this in a time series like
add a tenth of all like something like
data interval has value seven or
something the statement row has value
seven that datum who has rally eight how
is that going to work in time series yes
so the plan is that by providing a list
of date intervals it will automatically
switch to interpolation with order zero
assuming the answer yeah it's constant
values throughout those intervals and
then jumps okay
and something we have done in the
interval is always assuming that the
first instant is included but not the
last instant so I think we have a
collection of date intervals which are
back-to-back and there's no overlapping
that's kind of cool goodness
what should it return a quantity and
infinite quantity that should work
is there an infinite do infinite
quantities work yes now we might discuss
what their unit should be in any good
work I would add I would do use years
this works on coming up with it okay I
don't like the spacing here that is a
consistent bug which somebody really
needs to look at could could that get um
Kevin could you yeah yeah I can screen
share
okay I think the infinite feature in GMT
minus five is pretty crazy and that
should be fixed yes in fact the infinite
feature by itself has time some but fine
but I mean in the formatting it
shouldn't say GMT minus five
it's like you know at the very moment of
the Big Bang it was okay of the
competition
okay so now if I do this
hmm what does it think that is yes we
have discussed these and interval by
itself sort so this apparently different
I would accept so we discussed this at
some point the fact that interval sorts
its values but we wondered whether there
would be situations in which we want to
run backwards and so I think this is
left just for that case in case it's
needed why we're inside whatever the the
outer event horizon worker black hole
and time is running backwards or
something it's more like like range the
fact that in range we can get at least
that goes backwards I understand so
because we want eight interval to be
able to go to date range right actually
call on the live stream points out a
very very common case where you know the
death date of somebody with certainty
but not the birth date that's it that's
a good example that's a good clean
example um okay
project a feds points out what about two
fuzzy dates that both occur somewhere in
1995 but you don't know the order of the
dates
in other words two dates whose
granularity that is a can of worms right
so what happens if you have two dates
that are both let's say that have
granularity a month but there are only
15 days apart we don't support such
thing because once we insert a can
rarity of month that means the full
month is not a day with ICICI said it's
the month itself right but this is the
same thing as around you know 3 plus or
minus 0.2 person minus 2 is that greater
than around of 4 we just don't do
anything what could we possibly do with
that function saying can you resolve
this with this conference we would have
to provide more information some sort of
notion of how much overlapping do you
accept I don't think that's any I mean
if I said however this point 1 I see you
still don't resolve that it's not
resolved if they are fully separated if
they touch even at the border they don't
resolve but of course arounds are going
so well I don't know the Gaussian that
they're uncertain you know I suspect
we'll need an outer resolution function
here that as you say make certain
assumptions cuz that's gonna be annoying
that that can't resolve and I haven't
I'm surprised I haven't run into that
yet
ok ok fine let me just look at a few
other comments here
Carl is complaining that that there
isn't a way to turn polygon of geo
position into a region oh they will be
now in 12:1 so polygon of the opposition
and polygon of Geo grid position are
understood well if this is the would it
be polygonal so I try for example to get
a polygon off the US do in the US
polygon so this is returning the
graphics already can you replace shaper
by polygon
right so this is going to return the
polygon of your position that's useful
and now the regions function so now this
is written to you so if I say so what
can I do I could say something like and
what what projection is that what is
that yes the interpretation is the
following if if you use directly the Geo
position the polygon of your position
that's going to interpret as the 3d
object and yes and that's how it's
that's why it's returning something with
a depth however if you project it if you
do for example the ability position of
that polygon communicator then you can
do flat map operations so this is the
center of the US although is that the
center of the density within the US yeah
that's region centroid of that region so
what this is doing it's producing the 3d
are we not in Kansas anymore are we
still in Kansas here we're in Kansas
okay
Smith Center I wonder whether it knows
it's the geographic center who knows
sorry I let me not distract here um
okay good okay all right I understand um
so the important idea now is is the
difference between working on the map
with polygons of Jerry's position or
working with the full 3d you can do
those two you're saying yeah if you
project for example try to do the agree
position of that polygon communicator
the spring here that will project so now
we have that object which knows the
projection exactly and now you can do
that and of course this this computation
is projection dependent and that's why
I'll get back
so if I now say Jo nearest city of that
I'll get different cities cool and for
each projection do we get now we're in
abrasca now okay sorry go ahead
yeah yeah so this is nice because it's
it realizes the importance of the
projection and we can compare things for
different projections and see that's
very good very nice okay question here
is there a mechanism for converting an
existing range of dates and times eg a
time series into a date interval so in
other words if you say date interval
should give you the but why don't you
just update interval wrapping a time
series just give those date bounds it
seems like a good idea
okay um car is asking whether you can do
region I think you can region a percent
seventeen
to display that region right oh there it
is and because it's the position it's a
3d object wow that's pretty cool I have
never seen the u.s. actually a
disembodied honor that's really cool
okay I got to try one thing I'm sorry
I've just this is this is not in that oh
my gosh okay no more playing but anyway
let's just do this
why's it taking so long
wow that's cool well I think it's called
the least you could and you could
probably do a whole empty globe for the
whole world is so large that he'd take
quite some time um by the way where
should I store this Devon do you have a
suggestion yeah you I you have a folder
called geo functions and another one
called date functions if you're
concerned about either topic thank you
okay ah okay
all right um let's see
date interval should work with well with
timeline play yes what about date
intervals counting things like business
weeks does that work so given a date
interval if I want to know how many
business week so within that date
interval can I do that it isn't isn't
there a way of getting a date range
isn't what we can't you just say date
range right and if I say that oops
in other words resolve the date interval
into discreet dates of a certain
granularity within that data interval I
think so probably that means that's a
one argument form date range it's a
little odd that I think probably a good
idea um and the holiday calendar stuff
how is that we have a lot of data we
haven't got that we do have the
information in the okay okay a few other
comments here around greater than that
this Karl is saying that this reminds me
and distribution I'm not really sure
it's a distribution I don't know what it
is this is a weird kind of construct
well the comparison is it's just a weird
thing it's it's not it's truth value is
very weird yes I think that needs to be
handled via confidence I see I see there
what confidence interval I see that's a
good approach yeah that is a good
approach
um okay various comments about the fact
that you might know an animal is born
before it died but you but you don't
know in other words you might know yeah
I mean that's semantic information that
we're not dealing with here is quantity
array of vector around going to work
what to do with a raise of her arms
which may force us to have another type
of structure
but yes quantity array should be able to
extract the information from there from
a vector around certainly and produce a
quantity by a vector
yes okay Karl is asking if we're ever
going to have a polygon simplify regions
simplified for 2d and 3d meshes I
thought I mean we certainly have done a
ton of work on that for geo stuff I do
have internal functionality to do this
it's used in India manipulation but I
think Charles is planning to have this
type of functionality soon for this
reconstruction already and that would be
exposed to the use of circles if it
isn't maybe we should put something in
the function repository from what you
already have I'm still impressed with
this this is asking what we use date
interval for it's mostly for historical
research absolutely not it will be used
by your average financial quant trying
to figure out things about you know cash
flows or who knows what else very much a
current thing um okay and nothing else I
need to look at here with that no this
looks good I mean I I don't see a page
for example for infinite future and just
used to see the wording
of the Finnish monks because this is
kind of fun I'm standing in for a future
time with granularity eternity I guess
that's right yep seems right to me
looking good don't forget to put it on
guide pages maybe I'll have to do it at
some point
okay all right next um oh wait a minute
wait a minute Brian's asking the
station's will understand leap years
within a range and return the correct
number of years I would hope so correct
number of gays yeah I would certainly
hope so that's why date interval is
pinned to specific dates the question
about the fractal dimension of the u.s.
from polygons yes the answer is yes you
can do that but we will not do it in
real time here this is the next two
topics are things we have discussed and
okay so the idea was proposing here is a
way of getting from your position
already lists of the positions of
various depths and this problem is
present in all the four geo position
objects and all the four do vector
objects so I was looking for a solution
that can be applied to the eight of them
simultaneously the previous time we just
didn't like these combinations inside
lists and you suggested lists outside
things yeah you're probably right
okay so these are properties that will
be list 0 position oh my gosh geo
position list list yes that's the
position containing a list of lists of
points or a list of the opposition
containing list of points
hmm okay and yeah so this is just a
command of could we do this with flatten
itself and unfortunately we cannot
because flatten refuses to act on heads
that is a pity
well you could change that I mean what's
the argument structure of flatten after
they I mean there's a the second
argument Tony took us like a decade to
figure out how to do these later
arguments okay flattened so expressions
with head H what's what's wrong with
doing something with the third argument
there is a disconnect between the last
line and the third line I don't remember
the details right now but I was trying
to well okay so these are essentially
tensor contractions across different
levels is that correct yes so this means
right but the question is only whether
the head of the single news level if the
if they're h1 and h2 of the heads of two
different levels that are being
flattened out here what does that what
so since the new club will have as its
head like the s11 s12 etc all of those
should have the same and then the new
level has the same head but it doesn't
have to be the top level head and it
doesn't have to be the - I agree there
what's the problem others okay it is the
reason we don't make it work
column our livestream is suggesting
using allowed heads for flattened not a
terrible idea
[Music]
okay well if that worked how would that
affect our discussion about geo position
list list and how properly would that
have to be I mean how bizarre is it
gonna get get which people might get
used to I mean just like transpose I've
slowly gotten used to how to transpose
complicated you know nested deeply
nested arrays you know well look I don't
see a problem in introducing these
properties although they're quite
obscure but I think I think we kind of
have to obscure things to obscure ways
to do this then one will be the
generalization of flatten and the other
will be is very bizarre list your
position list properties here does that
seem reasonable okay
curry a friend curry oh my gosh so two
things so index kernel again I have the
code of operator and current anyone's
and then I have been thinking quite a
lot about okay well that's okay the
algebra employed by the new design I
think so I was trying to find relations
in the new scenario probably the
previous section is the most important
one that changes under discussion so
what we want to do is the current curry
would we renamed operator or something
else
operator still on the table
exactly I told Roger and immediately
said no because we will have in the
future different well as Roger dis Roger
I have a concrete suggestion for this
okay idea carry an operator are very
very similar it's me that the one
argument form I mean first to similar to
take go on one I mean who cares okay
okay
well I don't think we need to scale down
card but but basically the primary form
of curry would be as a as curried itself
so in those two things curry of F and
curry of brackets and F which one
converts to the other one if I think
following our standard approach of
operator forms the second should be an
input for the first one this this should
convert to this you're saying exactly
okay I'm not sure okay
curry three okay well that's Korean at
work okay sold on so this is now
operator
hmm why do this works because the
default default of operator is carrying
the second as we were doing before with
carry I have added a list of our current
rate of forms further down just to see
the overwhelming presence of the second
argument being correct well tell you
about that our current operator forms
I see okay yep okay so 62 take the
second argument and make that the Korea
Bowl thing exactly which was always our
argument for favoring that default
that's a little weird that the option
works but it okay yeah we have cases in
which we can put the options there or
the option on the in the first paragraph
into that
yes so this is the question of what is
an operator form is is the head only no
it's the whole thing I think is an
operator by the way there's a completely
you sound faint you sound perfectly
allowed to me Jose but but I don't know
if there's some difference in the way
you're setting set up you sound fine to
me I'm just seeing completely you don't
hear sounds good to me - okay all right
well okay um Jose I'll disappear because
you know it was time to adjust my
microphone okay okay go ahead as an
alternative name yes because yes it's
the symbol is there head of the operator
it it's an operator form once it gets
some arguments
I see I'll have to utterly obscure names
curry and operator ed we come out is
what goose call it headdress and be done
with it um okay let's explain again what
it's doing it says that blah blah blah
of f no it's its then blah blah blah of
F that creates an operator form this
thing creates or represents well that
combination is an operator form that
correct am I getting this right i mean
is that diem
yes so we had for example remember Q so
we would say operator of member Q comma
X comma X / sorry bracket bracket X yeah
so and that that's now something we can
apply to a list okay but what happens
when there's a comma the comma there is
just the structural information inside
the operator we really want a single
word here and you're right that this is
not itself the operator form so we have
until now that min of T of X is the
operator form I agree so this thing here
is not creating the operator form it's
creating the the thing which creates
that it's creating the pre operator form
exactly I wish that English had a
different you know I don't know whether
it's a gerund or some other because up
or you know the operator or operation or
something as the root seems right but if
we could only end it some other way
there was also trying to compare it to
function I think that's the next section
in the notebook okay you know somebody
should write some book about functional
programming in our language because
that's just to really it's a really rich
calculus of stuff that if people learnt
it well they would be very very
productive ok partial application this
is a more complicated I was looking at
the Wikipedia page for partial
application and he have those operators
do we care no not so much I was
wondering about the only fluting
operator on function okay I see on carry
makes no sense okay yes so I was trying
to find a parallelism between those two
important sounding words function
operator
so an operator of a function here I mean
if we say operator function X Y and then
we say f of X Y here what does that do
that applied to a B does that so one
question is whether if you just add a it
could do something
partially I know at the moment why was
it third it could insert the a inside oh
I see inside that function which is an
explicit exactly we turn a function of
one argument no of course the question
is whether it should return an operator
of that reduced function or the function
itself surely an operator other words
gonna be do a different thing isn't it
well if it was three arguments we would
want to insert one by one and for that
we need operator yeah okay let's let's
continue okay so look this is basically
an argument swap ah I mean this isn't
really I'm kind of beginning to think
that operator but what is this thing
doing really it is taking the thing
you've got and is allowing you to make
it into a you know I don't know enough
about all these things like opera ads
and so on it isn't any of those is it I
don't think so cannot tell for sure it's
some sort of delayed argument passing
you know it's a bad sign that I've
always looked up opera ads before
you
this is not completely irrelevant no
it's not I always that I have a look at
this
it is amazing how things get invented so
many times okay I think we still don't
have a name here I think we have the
semantics pretty well down yes we um
fine we really need to get bring this to
closure by 12.1 we need to have
something there um let me think about
this for a second look what this is
I'm still trying to describe what this
is it is a thing that takes the function
yeah
um yeah Brian our live stream is
suggesting operate over I don't think
that's quite right either I mean this is
you know because what this is doing that
whole construct is an operator form of F
this creates an operator form of F or
stands for represents an operator form
of F I just feel like it needs another
nee ending for operate what the hell is
operate oh this horrifying thing yes we
wanted to calm a bad head are we going
to rename it we discuss that it could
have been clearer name but I think we
should actually should provide the new
name and deprecated this one
particularly if we're gonna reuse
operate for something else can we after
so many years well keep this one working
it'll just have a big yellow stripe that
says it's deprecated yes I was referring
to using it for something else no we
cannot use this actual name for
something else but I think we should
deprecated this because I think it's a
bad name and I think nobody's used it
and it was a mistake in the original
design what are some other endings other
than operating operate operationalized I
mean these are made upwards
I'm somehow I'm thinking I'm and this is
a sign we should move on to the next
item in the agenda I'm beginning to
think it should be called something like
operatic um okay let's talk about time
remaining yes so this is something that
we already have internal context
oh it's part of the paws system or time
part of the time constraint yes and it
seems to work pretty well and for
example when you have nested some of
them nested it's able to realize you
which one is going to end sooner which
is quite quite interesting that isn't
trusting this looks good
I think we should just have it time
remaining does it have any arguments or
is it just um no I don't think it has
any elements I like it
let's do it yeah this can be useful for
various things inside contango strings
oh I'm happy to see that Ally on our
live stream is saying that he used up
they used to operate um and as Tobias H
is saying once a way to bypass multiple
arguments substituting them at the fault
values like in the horror of Lists
convolve yeah the whole question about
default values is a different one from
the one we're currently dealing well
that's not really different I think
that's not a problem we're gonna solve
in this round all right let's keep going
keep position yes this is just a
suggestion coming from Chris work and
they decide the question is whether we
need a function to find the position of
a key in a negotiation give me in the
actual position like the 1 2 3 4
position exactly the pneumatic position
or the index effectively because
possession in an association will give
the key right yes if you ask for the
value so if you ask for it where is a
given value okay you're saying where is
that key exactly and how does this
relate to other key star functions is
that consistent with how they work well
in general I don't think we have any
functionality that worries about the
position this is a bit against the
spirit of Association in the sense that
it shouldn't matter yeah I understand
and when I asked about in the possible
implementation for these a panel there
is no the the thing the implementation
does not allow a particularly efficient
way it will be just extracting there the
keys and doing a linear search okay the
name is kind of weird because key
what the heck is it because it isn't a
position I see what's mean it's good to
be an integer I understand that I
understand that which would work here if
I said um you know we can index that by
an integer right yes as a part
extraction thing but key position would
that work on a nested Association as
well associations in general are not
addressable when they are Nestor even
look up how do you do a lookup of
associations that are nested I'm not
sure um so so I I mean that I don't
think we need it
this function key position the
possibility of finding positions in
nested Association oh yeah let's suggest
the following to Chris why doesn't he
put something on the function repository
for this I'm not buying the idea that
this is a I mean I can see why he needs
it but I'm not sure that anybody else
will need it right I think he should put
something on the french repository for
it other a carl and live streamers is
commenting on having a progress
reporting option for map i fully agree
and we are trying to get a good general
progress reporting framework in place um
incidentally i have a nice utility
function i think it might be in coming
to the front repository soon which is
parallel map monitored which i've been
using every day here although
unfortunately it has a slightly
different version of the way it does
monitoring from map Oh whatever map
monitored whatever it is does but yes I
fully agree with that approach
okay data structure visualization I
think we kind of ran out of time here so
this will be considered a different time
um all right anything else for here for
right now yeah okay those interest on
the live stream and about a little bit
more than an hour we will be going on
with that data set design review and
thank you all very much lots of good
comments
much appreciated All Right see y'all
soon